I can literally hear my inner thoughts
it's true amazing easy with the balls
they attach to me why her eyes closed if
only damn my eyes open the crazies hell
yes it was phenomenal I was like you on
land you know everything that I wanted
girl feel that that's just for a half a
marathon need some electrolytes you know
I don't smoke nothing after say sir I'm
getting me some good yesterday right no
I got flavors the sports world was a
man's game I'm so sick of this boys club
I've never considered a female agent
until she found a way
I hired a psychic I can help you connect
with men why don't we have some teeth to
change the rules fYI you signed away oh
god I can hear my thoughts three threes
come to Papa I'm all-in
you didn't tell us your girl lady this
could change everything
I want a piece of that
just think what this is gonna do for
your sex life Oh what I'm about to do to
you that was phenomenal
it's like she read my oh I need some
electrolytes yesterday right now I got
flavors what men want
[Music]
you